una carrera presidencial que promete ser
una de las más polarizadas de la
historia de brasil el resultado de las
elecciones del 2 de octubre se decidiera
entre el candidato de izquierdas lula
dasilva y el ultraderechista ya ir
bolsonaro en arranque de campaña nula
acusó al gobierno de bolsonaro de mentir
a su base electoral y
quiere decirle presidente genocida que
no queremos un gobierno que distribuye
armas queremos un gobierno que
distribuya libros no queremos un
gobierno que alimente el odio queremos
un gobierno que alimente el amor estas
últimas semanas para suavizar su imagen
ante los votantes que les son
históricamente hostiles lula aumentó sus
reuniones con líderes empresariales y
eligió al ex gobernador conservador del
estado de sao paulo geraldo alckmin como
compañero de fórmula
por otro lado la campaña de jair
bolsonaro vive una dinámica inesperada
desde hace unos días a mediados de julio
el presidente liberó casi 8.000 millones
de dólares de gasto público para las
clases más vulnerables y sigue centrando
su discurso en la y la moral cristiana
con el objetivo de recuperar al
electorado evangélico que le votó
masivamente en 2018 y representa más de
un tercio de la población
nuestro país no quiere dar pasos atrás
no queremos ideología de género en las
escuelas nuestro país no quiere
legalizar las drogas nuestro país
respeta la vida desde su concepción
nuestro país no quiere convertirse en un
aliado del comunismo en otros países sin
embargo según las encuestas nulas sigue
siendo el favorito y para jair bolsonaro
el desafío es todavía considerable el
presidente lo apuesta todo al 7 de
septiembre día del bicentenario de la
independencia y fecha en la que tiene
previsto organizar grandes
concentraciones en todo el país